[Musique]
bonsoir est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau cette ut le journal le
premier de l'année 2017
voici les titres les premiers flocons
dans les yvelines à saint-quentin
quelques précipitations eu lieu en fin
de matinée les services techniques se
mettent à pied d'oeuvre pour affronter
l'hiver
les ventes de paquets de cigarettes
neutres sont devenus obligatoires depuis
hier une mesure qui a pour but de lutter
contre le tabac mais qui est contesté
par les buralistes
et puis le début de l'année souvent
l'occasion de prendre de bonnes
résolutions qu'attendez vous pour 2017
on débute ce journal avec une triste
nouvelle le décès aujourd'hui de
l'ancien secrétaire général de la cfdt
françois chérèque
il est mort à 60 ans des suites d'une
leucémie diagnostiquée en 2015
melchior palacio au secrétaire général
de l'union départementale cfdt attrape
rend hommage au combat du syndicaliste
il est mélangé facilement avec les
militants et discuter avec eux c'est
quelqu'un de très proche on pouvait lui
parler librement et ils sont sans avoir
à y remédier en effectuant des réponses
eu assez assez facilement avec lui est
une pile artisans de je dirais du des
dialogues ceci alors général il a fait
beaucoup en disant pour les faire
évoluer le paysage syndical et de la
façon de négocier et de discuter et on
passe un tout autre sujet des premiers
flocons pointer le bout de leur nez dans
les yvelines à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
quelques précipitations ont même eu lieu
en fin de matinée des services
techniques du département se met à pied
d'oeuvre pour affronter l'hiver les
premiers flocons de l'année 2017 sont
tombés ce lundi de janvier
placés en vigilance orange par météo
france avec 17 autres départements les
yvelines ont observé quelques chutes de
neige en fin de matinée
on a suivi depuis le tout début de
journée une perturbation assez faible
qui descendait du nord donc qu'il irait
vers nous donc elle a d'abord touché le
val d'oise ensuite le nord des dix line
et puis ensuite est arrivé sur sur saint
quentin en yvelines donc en fait d'abord
nous quelques petites pluies mais
ensuite ces petites pluies on se sont
transformés en plus et neige mêlées nf
sol un épisode de courte durée la neige
n'a pas tenu et la vigilance orange a
été levée en milieu de journée mais les
services techniques du département
restent en alerte
il couvre une trentaine de communes pour
le centre de saint cyr l'école
nous avons quatre camions
pour le service hivernal et chaque
camion fait 4 mètres cubes 4 mètres
cubes équivaut à peu près 10 tonnes
l'enjeu est une question de sécurité
pour les usagers pour qu'ils puissent en
fait le nir au travail à partir de 6
heures le matin
alors toute sécurité météo france
prévoit de nouvelles gelés dans la nuit
avec un risque de brouillard givrant et
des températures entre -4 et -2 degrés
attention donc au verglas et aux plaques
de glace une prudence à respecter pour
le reste de la semaine
augmentation du smic don d'organes ou
encore allègement de la procédure liés
au divorce 2017 apporte son lot de
changements
parmi eux aussi la vente de paquets de
cigarettes neutres obligatoire depuis
hier une mesure qui a pour but de lutter
contre le tabac mais qui est contestée
notamment par les buralistes les marques
c'est fini place aux paquets neutres
depuis le 1er janvier seuls ces types de
paquets sont vendus une mesure peu
convaincante pour certains fumeurs moi
je suis contre pourquoi parce que
j'étais passat l'empêchera les gens de
fumer ça votre chien par les buralistes
web pour retrouver dans l'état pack
avance t rouge vert et cetera maintenant
ça va des faits c'est pour eux c'est de
la folie et c'est une aberration
parce que ça sert à rien dégueulasse des
paquets noah avec des images choquantes
pour inciter à arrêter de fumer
une contrainte selon les buralistes qui
ont écoulé les stocks des dernières
cigarettes classiques
le ministre nous a affirmé que tous nos
fournisseurs ne reprendrait les paquets
non vendus donc ce qui nous permet de ne
pas avoir de pertes
quand on reçoit des commandes tout et
tout est à même couleur même format
c'est c'est horrible c'est vrai pour
travailler c'est ta pas été du tout
pensé pour nous en tout cas on comprend
pas l'impact que cela peut avoir
je suis en vie ce film est une brave le
prix et efficace je pense que aussi
c'est de la prévention de l'éducation
et puis mes l'interdît l'interdît n'a
jamais n'a jamais coupé court à la
consommation autre levier du
gouvernement pour lutter contre le
tabagisme la fiscalité la loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale de 2017
prévoit une taxe spécifique sur les
fournisseurs et un relevé du taux sur le
tabac à rouler un but son gré vous
pouvez acheter des crêpes
est ce que ça vous tente eh bien depuis
le mois de novembre dernier un foutraque
s'est installé sur le parking du magasin
truffaut à plaisir une idée originale
que l'on doit un élan courtois
christophe et bling du taxi londonien au
bus à impériale anglais avec l'union
jack aux côtés de la croix bretonne
après avoir aménagé son véhicule
christophe et bling a ouvert sa crêperie
le 1er novembre dernier
coût total de l'investissement 40000
euros nouvelle aventure petit coup de
folie on achète un bus anglais ont la
ménage en crêperie mobile ça peut être
sympa déjà géré un peu plus de place au
cas échéant les gens peuvent rester à
l'intérieur c'est un peu ma marque de
fabrique c'est la crêperie bretonne avec
des avec des véhicules anglais quoi une
odeur de crêpes plane dans ce bus
anglais les installations d'origine
côtoient les décorations bretonne sur
les écriteaux des conseils pour réaliser
la galette parfaite
on attend que la galette cuisse ces
centres sont s'aperçoit que la galette
et bien cuites
ap atelier au moment où les bords vont
commencer un peu à se relever
on va faire une complète exotiques
s'appelle la brique l'ouest va bien que
le bus anglais
donc c'est une galette of applause du
jambon c'est du bacon imploser les
mental c'est du cheddar pour
rentabiliser son projet christophe
espère attirer sa clientèle du taxi pour
venir dans son bus et des entreprises à
proximité des clients déjà au rendez
vous je trouve ça le concept génial de
pouvoir déplacer son restaurant comme ça
à sa guise
et puis en plus c'est bon c'est très
sympa c'est très rapide pour nous parce
qu'on a très peu de temps pour manger
donc c'est extrêmement rapides pour nous
on a le temps de se poser on est dans un
cadre différent
ouvert les mercredis vendredis midi la
crêperie accueille en moyenne 15
personnes ce chiffre atteint la
cinquantaine le week end
un concept qui commence à rouler eh bien
ça donne envie et dans le reste de
l'actualité la dame noire
le club d'échecs de montigny le
bretonneux organisé la semaine dernière
son 17e tournoi de noël un tournoi
remporté cette année par un adhérent de
l'association reportage de nicolas quere
l'oit
il n'a que 18 ans un sourire un brin
gêné face à certains joueurs mieux
classés que lui à cyril fruchart membres
de la dame noire a remporté vendredi 30
décembre le 17e tournoi de noël organisé
par son club
une surprise pour l'intéressé est loin
d'être favori au départ c'est vrai que
ce n'était pas tendu au départ
au départ c'était le il y avait m
entends d un maître fide il aurait dû
gagner
il était favori contre le maître creed
par exemple il est fait dit il mais il a
peu raté son ouverture du coup une
partie facile j'ai et c'était surtout
lui qui devait défendre et donc c'était
plus facile pour moi
six victoires et un match nul c'est le
bilan presque parfait de cyril fruchart
pour ce tournoi de noël une performance
qui rend fier à celles et ceux qui l'ont
vu évoluer depuis l'âge de 9 ans au sein
de son club dans le temps il y avait des
grands maîtres joueurs professionnels
qui ont participé à cette heure là ils
n'ont pas gagné mais bon nous sommes
toujours plus content qu'un jeune des
clubs qui à être formés et grandit au
lac nous l'avons connue depuis l'âge de
6 ans s'étendent maintenant âgé de 19
ans égale de tournoi nous sommes très
très contents mais c'est personnel
elle sépare nos clubs est toujours
content que les jeunes gagnent en tout
43 joueurs ont participé au tournoi
organisé par la dame noire le prochain
rendez vous pour les passionnés de
l'échiquier fixée au mois de mai ils
tenteront alors de mettre échec est la
nouvelle pépite local la ville de
guyancourt a organisé durant les
vacances de noël plusieurs activités à
destination des enfants
parmi elles un stage de vidéo de stop
motion qui se déroulait à la villa
simone signoret le
de l'atelier réalisé un court métrage
sur le thème solidarité afrique écriture
de scénario confection de mini décor
réalisation ou encore montage voilà les
ateliers proposés aux enfants de la
ville de guerre en cours des activités
qui les passionne ça se passe bien bas
au début j'avais jamais essayé nos stops
prochaine après au fil au fil du temps
et des condensats à comprendre
on pense avec quelque chose ça vient
après ben on a une idée on essaye de le
faire et après ben c'est après le reste
et de l'improvisation le début c'était
compliqué mais après enfin je crois que
je me suis bien amusé on a fait on a
fait bouger les personnages on a fait ce
qu'on voulait tremblement terre autre
chose c'était très bien et pour les
petits spielberg en herbe le but de
l'atelier est de découvrir et s'initier
au stop motion
c'est un système d'animation qui date
depuis très longtemps c'est d'être
depuis le début du cinéma
donc c'est une technique qui consiste à
faire bouger un beau justin objets
immobiles et à la finlande exemple vous
avez 6 avec king kong en noir et blanc
en pâte à modeler ça c'est dit stop
motion c'est à dire que on part sur un
objet on va animer avec la pâte à
modeler et c'est ça et à la fin on le
déplace un petit peu on prend des photos
et à la fin en assemblant les photos on
en voit l'objet qui bouge et durant les
deux semaines plus de 5000 photos ont
été prises les différents courts
métrages ont été visionnées par les
enfants ce week end le début de l'année
est souvent l'occasion de prendre de
bonnes résolutions
nous sommes allés à votre rencontre pour
connaître les vôtres en 2017
tout d'abord je souhaite la santé à tout
le monde et puis la réalisation de tous
leurs voeux les plus chers plein de
projets réussis pour pour les jeunes en
particulier la santé essentiels même que
tous faire du sport je suis fière et à
l'heure malgré la neige savoir pour qui
voter
dans cinq mois parce que j'en ai aucune
idée
et aucun aucune personne ne m'attirent
nm convaincu encore que les français
votent correctement aussi parce souayah
indécis sur l'un ou sur l'autre
santé bonheur pour tout le monde et la
paix dans le monde
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal
prochaine édition demain et surtout
bonne année à tous
[Musique]